so hey everyone I'm Byung I work at
source craft and today I'm lucky you
about some patterns and examples that we
came up with building source crap as a
go web app and just want to share that
with you and get your thoughts so just
really quick for some context oh by the
way feel free to interrupt me at any
point in this talk I kind of want to ask
a question you'll actually get a free
t-shirt like this if you do so there's
your incentive what's up Oh
seven
all right cool okay so first off just a
little context who we are and why we're
talking about building a web app so
source crap is a source of code engine
written in go so who here is credible
source crap before okay cool
a lot of you for those of you who don't
know what it is it's a source code
engine source code search engine written
go and one of the things it does that's
unique to it that's not in other what
search engines is that it indexes things
in a semantic level so it actually goes
through it parses the code understands
what functions are and what function
calls are and serves you that instead of
indexing just the plain text so you can
actually search directly for functions
and types and packages by name and it
supports go and serve other languages
and when you serve for something on
source grab you jump to the definition
of where that thing is in code and you
also see usage examples of how other
people use that particular piece of code
how they're calling it who else is using
it and things like that and the high
level motivation behind this building
source graph was that we had this pain
that we felt as programmers we're you
know we wanted it to more easily figure
out how to use other people's code and
explore around it and see what patterns
and best practices they did so what this
does is it makes it easier to jump
around code on the definition find
usages things like that and just as a
side note it's free to use and is also
going to be mostly open-source soon
we're gonna open source logging language
analysis packages that we use so if
you're interested in building things
like editor plugins or browser
extensions or just developer tools in
general and want
of you know this library that parses the
code and you know resolves references
and things like that come talk to me
afterwards so I'm going to talk about
building the web apps but I'm not here
to talk about how we build source
crapcom actually so that actually is
another talk so if anyone here was at
Google i/o anyone here see our Google
i/o talk okay it's very few of you so if
you're interested in learning or seeing
how we build some scrap comm there is a
talk that covers that it covers a lot of
the same patterns and principles I'm
going to discuss here but the difference
is that this talk is going to focus on a
different web app that we built using
these principles and is now completely
open source
there's also another clock specifically
about testing so this talk is how we
apply the patterns and examples we came
up with while building for scrap comm to
build a cool go web app in under 24
hours so what is the site actually so
it's called the source
org it's actually live right now and
it's a grew out of this personal dream
that we had that you know what if there
was a community site out there where you
could share links and that were
specifically just about programming and
code and it didn't have things like you
know how I act my latest funding around
or how the NSA is written your email or
just random Silicon Valley gossip so we
just decided to hey look let's try and
build this thing and we also view this
as a navarre contribution to the
conversation that's happening
about how to structure and build web
apps so we think that what we've come up
with are a lot of general people
patterns that hopefully will help other
people when they're building their own
going what so not only the site live but
the code is on github it's completely
open-source check it out right now and
you know send feedback so that's what it
looks like it's it looks very similar to
your typical link sharing site right now
just pulls from hacker news and the
programming subreddit and just hides all
the links that don't actually contain
code snippets so it looks for like code
and 3d tags and they should not so let's
get back to the problem at hand which is
how do we build and structure a good go
web app so what I should what I'm
showing here is essentially like the
Platonic form of what the source the
source tab or it does so I reduced it to
just three things and I listed them in
representation that hopefully everyone
here will understand ago interface right
so what does the web app what does this
particular web app actually do it lets
you you know get a post it lets you list
a bunch of posts and it lets you submit
a post and that's what you do as a user
and that's what that's what the app does
right so remember this slide this is
what it does and a quick aside you know
in general what makes a good you know
web application obviously it needs to be
functional and needs to support the
functionality that just showed or
whatever the spec is it needs to be
performant it'd be nice if there's an
API to interact with it but more
importantly you know how high should the
code be structured and you know one you
know high-level principle is DRI DRI or
don't repeat yourself basically what
that means is you don't
right repetitive code because then it's
not gonna be readable it's gonna be a
pain to maintain you're gonna have to
make updates in multiple places and it's
gonna be hard to test because you're
gonna have to basically repeat yourself
in tests as well and that sort of D
incentivizes you from writing tests so
what is the what is the architecture of
a typical web app and this particular
what that looked like so you know this
should be fairly familiar to everyone
here the user issues masonry requests by
navigating to a URL in the browser that
hits the web front-end server that
server in turn calls the API server
issues an HTTP request API server which
then issues requests to the database the
database returns that data that data
gets marveled at the API level adds
something like JSON and then in the web
front-end it takes that JSON and stuffs
it into some sort of HTML rendering
system and returns HTML to a user so to
start with you know looking at this
picture the starting point for many
people when they start to build a web
application is to think about how to tie
all this together so what is like the
framework that you're fitting this all
into so we actually can use a
traditional web framework what we found
is that we were able to get really far
just using the things in the ghost hair
library and a few narrowly focused
third-party libraries you know like
gorilla mocks for equal our URL routing
and you know the model or mobile library
for interacting with our database and
really on top of that we just
implemented a couple of helper functions
that sort of you know do things that way
up
we do like render some HTML or you know
mark.wilson JSON so this line has a lot
of code and you know again all the code
is open source online github so check it
out if you want to see you don't dive
into it so that's sort of like the high
level you know how are you tying all
this together now you know what about
getting back to those high level goals
about what makes a good web app you know
and one of one of the things was don't
be yourself so how are we going to
eliminate repetition in this design
because if you think about there's a lot
of repeated logic here you know the web
front-end is doing some things running
HTML but it has to interact the same
data structures conceptually as the API
in the datastore right so remember that
platonic form of what the app web app
was I wrote it as a go interface to
describe it succinctly and that's it
describes what it is both at like a UI
level all the way down to you know the
database level and one of the things
that we found is we could actually make
it a literal interface in our code and
that this interface actually is common
it's implemented by you know all three
layers essentially so you know add at
the API layer you're gonna have
something that you know gets a post what
that's going to do is it's going to talk
to the datastore layer same thing for
lists and submit right and at the the
web front-end layer it's essentially
doing the same thing it's just going to
talk to the API layer instead of talking
in the datastore right so they're the
same interface they just have different
implementations so this is what you know
the implementation of the API client
would look like so again you know what
you're asking you to do is give you a
post which is simple what it doesn't
meet the hood
it just instructs the URL issues request
for that URL to the EDI which returns it
as JSON and then it decodes that JSON
under principles and then again for the
datastore you know you're gonna ask the
datastore for a post but instead of you
know doing a back client did it's going
to issue a sequel query and get the data
from the database and return to you any
questions so far
Oh dalla one is just it's just embedding
the argument into the sequel the idea
argument so that's just how this
particular package doesn't anyone lost I
know it's a lot of code okay what's up
uh yeah so this this code might be a
little like reformatted for display
purposes okay so now we've made those
two things implement the same interface
so that's what applies us kind of like
nice you know code style there including
the same interface it feels good but
what about you know oh another thing is
that if you end up changing that
interface it will break the layers at
compile time if you have not Big Ben so
instead of you know making decided you
want to change something on the front
end and then oops like I forgot to
change the interface in the subsequent
layers because you know they don't
actually implement same interface in
code and find that error at runtime now
you have like a compile time guarantee
that they actually implement this
interface which describes we graph does
but more than just that it helps you
simplify a lot of things so it
specifically you know we started cast
each of these layers as including that
interface and the thing that sort of
sits between the layers are these h-2b
handlers and when you first start
writing web app you might stuff a lot of
logic in the HTTP handlers so in
addition to just you know handling the
HTTP request it does a lot of other
things like it talks to the layers below
it and things like that now by using
this common
face you can make it so that the HP
handlers just deal with parsing and
handling the HTTP requests and then
immediately forwards that to the API
client or datastore which handles
talking to the layers below so it's sort
of nice and capsulation
and that happens both you know at the
front-end server level and the API
server level so there's the diagram and
just refresh our memory and another
thing we can do is we can unify the
routing and generation of routes so one
common thing that happens when you
implement a web app and you want to you
know create an API client for it is you
have your nice URL router which defines
all your routes really nicely and it's
great and then you go to England Navy
API client and what happens is you have
hard code a lot of these routes into the
API client because you don't want your
API client to depend on the API server
that would be terrible
right so you just hard-coded and then
what happens when you change your
definition of the routes in your API
server it breaks the API client right so
what we did is we actually extracted the
router component of the API server so
that now this is a separate router
package that both the API client and the
API server depend upon and all the
router package does is to find the
routes
it doesn't actually attach handlers to
the routes that's done in the API server
package so that allows us to basically
clean them do nice route generation in
the you guys claim that will not break
if you change the definition of your
rats oh and so you can also apply this
to the front-end server if it's similar
enough to your API server in this case
it is because all we're doing is getting
and creating posts there's nothing fancy
happening in front it's a very thin
layer on top they go yeah that's
basically what I just said and then
another another nice wind we get from
this is we can share parameters across
layers so you know for any given
endpoint and your API or your web app
you're going to want to pass some query
parameters to that so like you know when
you list all the definitions and
repository and source graph for instance
you wanted to find some sort order like
sort by how many people use it you pass
that as a query parameter and in a you
know if you're not doing it if you're
doing it for the naive way you end up
repeating the definition of those
options at each layer right because each
layer has to
Marse those unmarshal them re-- marshal
them pass them on the next layer and now
they're just completely sure and finally
another one we get is it makes it a lot
easier to test because all three layers
implement this common interface and we
can mock that interface by essentially
you know this struct this truck
implements that laconic form of the app
that interface and all it contains is a
bunch of stuff functions that you can
override your tests to you know make
whatever layer is above or below the
layer that you're testing right now and
yeah it it just makes it so you don't
have to repeat that at each layer so it
makes it you know let's work on your
part to test this application well and
in other ways if you're releasing your
API client to the public you can also
release the mock to that API client
and so not only are your tests nice but
other people who are using and building
on copyright can also have nice tests
and just obviously a high level a
general wind up using mocks is that
you're only testing one part of the your
application at time and the test will
run super fast because they're not going
to hit the database or anything like
that so there it is again
the sort of generic web app architecture
diagram hopefully all the things I
covered you can sort of fit into this
picture is there any questions but yeah
you drive
where you just house a web client and
you have to have to just meant that face
again
oh so the question is how did we get our
API client to be dry did we have to
essentially re-implement it in
JavaScript and the answer is so the HTML
in our app is actually generated
server-side so the front end is written
in go if we had you know like a single
page JavaScript app we would have to
re-implement
all this stuff and JavaScript any other
questions
yep what's that
oh you're asking about how we do the
encoding and decoding of The Cranberries
so these these are just some small
third-party libraries that just make it
easier to you know go from a go struct
to a query screen and vice versa yeah so
that's all that is and once again the
code is all online so if you want to
check it out and see how it's done in
practice yeah
so don't come talk to me afterwards it's
a bit much to get in yeah yeah
so I think what so one of the things is
originally let me go back
so this slide this this thing is
actually something that we noticed that
when we were making this new map in in
actual source crapcom we separated the
definition of the API routing and from
the apps that were front-end routing and
in this case the you know platonic form
that the interface was actually simple
enough that we could actually combine
both of those in the same package so
it's just another place where good
eliminate repetition any other questions
yeah
a bill to go install yeah I mean we just
use the standard yeah although so we do
we use go Deptford dependency management
that's the only kind of kink okay okay
so once again the code is online the
directory structure is pretty much
mapped out to what I just described and
let's just revisit our goals really
quick so obviously it's functionally can
check that source the source org is
performant because the ghost game
library is very performant and you know
you saw all the other libraries that we
use it's a very thin layer on top loop
for what the same library provides and
the code itself is is very dry you know
we unified the URL routing the route
generation on there and stuff the
interfaces are easy amok so it's it's
testable and you know we almost found
the high quality API plant as a side
effect of ripping that out that
interface because all the API client
does is implement that interface and
just issue HTTP requests underneath that
so as the meta points the the slides in
stock are are up here
oh and you know how did we come up with
these patterns so we didn't just pull
them out of thin air we actually got
them by reading through a lot of the
code in the standard lab and also
third-party libraries that we used and
observing the patterns and examples of
how people are doing things there and I
think that's a really good way of sort
of like leveling up as a programmer and
in a given language is to see whether
people are are doing and I think source
graph is really good tool for doing that
because you can just easily explore code
click on links and finally a disclaimer
yeah this approach is what worked for us
at source graph and also building the
source but obviously it's not the
end-all be-all you know a Bible of how
to build web apps and go so we want your
feedback we want you to tell us what's
stupid or wrong about this approach and
what we can do better and check out this
rest I work and unless what you think
any questions yeah yeah all odd you know
sorry about that yeah
yeah so I survey glossed over this point
but when I was talking about like our
quote unquote framework what we actually
do is so go makes it really easy to
compose HTTP handlers so you can you
know wrap yeah you have your handle that
actually implements your application
logic but you also have these other
things that you want to do for every
request like logging or authentication
and things like that so what we actually
do is when we define our actual you know
app logic handlers we wrap them this is
a typo it's not a wrapper function but
it we wrap them in a type and what that
type does is it implements the HTTP
handle function so it is an HP Handler
and inside its each bit sorry inside its
handle function it does all the things
that you want to do for each request
like off and logging and then calls the
function that it wraps if it gets an
error it writes an H Pierre to the the
response writer otherwise it just
returns whatever or sorry it doesn't
return e just you know passes on the
response
yeah so there's a third point live
called its gorilla stock context I think
which allows you to set context
variables for a given HTTP request and
so you can set that context data in a
you know upstream handler and then
access it in in the dance with members
any other questions yeah
oh sorry the question was do I know of
any other frameworks for URL routing
besides guerrilla I don't know any off
the top my head actually does anyone
else know knee
Frank works like
yeah oh there's a URL routers and go
frameworks that take more traditional
and homework approach HDPE route he
should be ready
sorry what was in the record 8gb router
and gin check this out
any other questions all right cool thank
you very much